[Musique]
votre émission parlement hebdo bonjour à
tous deux journalistes un parlementaire
qu'on passe au grill de nos questions
aujourd'hui avec michael braun piv et
présidente de la commission des lois de
l'assemblée nationale bonjour bonjour et
c'est katia qui brosse votre portrait
bonjour style et bonjour yale brûle-t-il
et vous êtes député l'un république en
marge des yvelines avocate de formation
engagé dans le monde associatif
notamment aux restos du coeur
alors vous êtes élu à l'assemblée
nationale pour la première fois depuis
2010 est donc vous êtes une jeune élue
et vous présidez la puissante commission
des lois de l'assemblée steve l'a dit
alors en 2019 avec la sphère benalla
vous êtes sous les feux de la rampe en
tant que co rapporteur de la commission
d' enquête parlementaire en 2020 vous
déposez notamment une proposition de loi
qui vise à instaurer des mesures de
sûreté pour les terroristes sortant de
prison
yelle brunn qui vivait il y à une pile
de texte très important qui vous attend
juillet anti terrorisme séparatiste
réforme constitutionnelle travail
parlementaire ou réforme un peu
politique à dix mois de la
présidentielle
alors comme vous le savez la commission
des lois est au coeur de l'état en
termes de sujets qu'elle traite et c'est
ça qui est passionnant donc tous les
sujets que nous traitons sont vraiment
des sujets qui intéressent nos
concitoyens et qui considèrent qu'ils
constituent vraiment le creuset de notre
république et donc ça n'est pas
particulièrement électoralistes c'est
vraiment la continuité de l'état qui
s'incarne dans les teasers de bataille
politique sur ces textes alors que
l'ambiance est un peu agité vous n'avez
pas peur de ça non parce que les enjeux
nous dépasse on parle du climat et ça
c'est des enjeux qui concerne toutes les
générations et les générations futures
quand on parle de sécurité de terrorisme
on n'est pas sur des sujets politiques
d' affrontements stériles en et sur la
protection des français et leur sécurité
donc évidemment ces enjeux là nous
dépasse tous et je crois et moi c'est
comme cela que je les aborde à
l'assemblée et que je les aborde avec
mon collègue sénateur françois noël
buffet nous les abordons à chaque fois
en responsabilité parce que nous savons
que les sujets sont trop importants pour
en faire des espèces de petites joutes
politiciennes qui
justement tard justement chez vous
l'ambiance elle est assez animé en ce
moment clash entre gérald darmanin à
eric dupond-moretti explication de texte
entre barbara pont pie elisabeth bande
le président du groupe la république en
marche ici au sénat françois patriat dit
peut-être que finalement le parti en
marche est un peu à bout de souffle
peut-être qu'il va falloir passer un
grand mouvement de la majorité
présidentielle qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous je ne partage pas l'analyse
du à bout de souffle
moi tous les jours je vois sur le
terrain des militants des citoyens qui
se sont engagés avec en marché qui croît
et qui croient au dépassement des
clivages plus que tout alors le
réorganiser faire une analyse au vue des
scrutins qui se sont écoulées et pour la
préparer la présidentielle
ça ça me paraît essentiel mais en
revanche d'ouverture on m'a alors je ne
sais pas il faudra regarder ce qu'il
convient de faire au mieux mais moi je
peux vous assurer que sur le terrain on
a des militants on a des citoyens qui y
croient et qui croient plus que jamais
il va falloir passer procéder à un
remaniement sur le nouveau après les
régionales on évoque beaucoup on évoque
beaucoup vous savez à chaque scrutin on
évoque remaniement changement était du
parti changement ce que vous faisiez
travaux parlementaires
moi je pense que il faut toujours
regarder analyser un scrutin est pas au
milieu des échéances là on est entre les
deux tours donc il trouve adorable pour
analyser ça on verra après et il faut
analyser ça de façon très pragmatique et
pas à chaud et regarder ce qui est mieux
de faire dans une stratégie globale à
les questions passées au sommaire de
l'émission
oui avec la promesse d' emmanuel macron
d'inscrire la protection du climat dans
la constitution aux côtés de la laïcité
est donné
alité problème députés et sénateurs ne
sont toujours pas d'accord sur la
formulation exacte ce qui risque de
compromettre le référendum voulu par le
président de la république semaine
compliquée pour gérald darmanin au sénat
le ministre de l'intérieur a été
auditionné à la suite des ratés
constatés à l'occasion du premier tour
des élections régionales et c'est
officiel le sénat lance une commission
d' enquête pour faire toute la lumière
sur cette affaire
[Applaudissements]
et puis après le niveau historique de
l'abstention au premier tour des
régionales et départementales le
président de l'assemblée nationale
annoncé qu'il prendrait des initiatives
pour lutter contre l'abstention vote par
correspondance sur internet on demandera
notre invité ce qu'elle en pense le
climat sera t'il inscrits aux côtés de
la laïcité de l'égalité dans la
constitution la question est en tout cas
à l'ordre du jour au parlement
[Musique]
les députés ont voté une nouvelle
version du projet de loi
constitutionnelle mais toujours pas le
même texte que les sénateurs
c'est pourtant la condition pour que le
référendum voulu par emmanuel macron ait
lieu explications avec elsa mondain gava
ce sont 18 mo qui occupent l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat
le gouvernement veut modifier l'article
premier de la constitution
une des propositions de la convention
citoyenne en première lecture
l'assemblée a voté la formulation du
gouvernement la france garantit la
préservation de l'environnement et de la
diversité biologique et lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique
puis le sénat a réécrit l'article elle
préserve l'environnement ainsi que la
diversité biologique et agit contre le
dérèglement climatique
la majorité propose cette fois un
compromis la france gars entier à
préservation de l'environnement et de la
diversité biologique et agit contre le
dérèglement climatique nous avons en
effet entendu les réserves relatives à
l'emploi de chevaux lutter et sont prêts
pour parvenir à un texte qui soit votée
dans les mêmes termes par les deux
chambres à faire ce pas vers le sénat et
parce qu'il souhaite maintenir la force
de son ambition le gouvernement tient
également au maintien dans le projet de
l'affirmation selon laquelle la france
garantit la préservation de
l'environnement
pas de quoi convaincre la droite ni à
l'assemblée ni au sénat
si je devais prendre une métaphore c'est
comme le choix du prénom d'un enfant
le papa peut de toutes ses forces avoir
en tête le plus beau prénom du monde
si la maman dit non c'est non la
révision constitutionnelle
c'est un petit peu la même chose vous
pouvez avoir la meilleure idée du monde
pour sa passe
il faut que ces dates disent oui un vote
des deux chambres sur un texte identique
c'est la condition pour organiser un
référendum
finalement l'assemblée n'a pas changé
grand chose dans le texte mais pourquoi
il ya lebron pv vouloir à tout prix
garder ce terme de garantir qui est
contraignant qui induit une obligation
pour les entreprises parce que l'enjeu
il nous dépasse on vient d'avoir cette
semaine le sixième rapport du giec qui
nous dit quoi
qui nous dit que tout s'accélère et que
les impacts du réchauffement climatique
on va les voir beaucoup plus tôt que
prévu donc les enjeux sur le climat sur
la biodiversité sur l'environnement il
nous dépasse et il faut absolument agir
et agir vous avez une contrainte donc
nous ce que l'on veut c'est plat c'est
l'ambition de la préservation de
l'environnement et de la biodiversité
très haut
c'est ce que les citoyens de la
convention citoyenne ont souhaité ils
ont demandé un référendum c'était la
seule mesure sur laquelle ils ont dit
non on veut questionner les français et
c'est normal parce que questionner les
français sur cet enjeu là qui les
concerne tous
je crois que c'est quelque chose de très
fort et finalement j'ai envie de dire au
sénat mais laissez les français nous
dire à quel niveau ils veulent la
mission le problème de ce référendum
c'est qu'il va falloir un compromis avec
le sénat les sénateurs mais ils disent
qu'ils n'ont pas des changes
actuellement avec vous aucun échange
comment vous expliquez ça en moi j'ai
toujours des échanges en tout cas avec
mon homologue françois noël buffet on se
choisit la commission avec william ans
et on se tait on travaille très bien
ensemble je crois aujourd'hui que
l'assemblée nationale a fait un pas on
aurait pu dire pas de dialogue si
effectivement on reprend notre version
telle quelle
et puis on avance et c'est comme ça pas
autrement
ce n'est pas le choix que nous avons
fait nous nous considérons que l'enjeu
climatique est tellement important qu'il
faut arriver à un compromis
donc nous avons fait avec les femmes 25
ou ses politiques vont envoyer
finalement la responsabilité vers le
sénat vous pensez vraiment qu'il y aura
un référendum
- je voudrais encore une fois que nos
concitoyens sont tellement concerné par
l'enjeu climatique
excellent jeu climatique il nous dépasse
tellement et qu'il devient urgent d'agir
qu'il faut que le peuple français se
prononcent sur le niveau d'ambition qui
le souhaitent et qu il
souhaite que les politiques incarnées
mettent en oeuvre donc vraiment nous
avons fait un pas maintenant j'invite
nos collègues sénateurs à faire un pas
vers nous et ensemble nous pourrons
soumettre au peuple français
s'il vous président de la république le
souhaitent cette ambition et le peuple
français nous dira un nous dira ce qu'il
souhaite que l'on fasse mais avant cela
il faut donc un texte commun six députés
et sénateurs échoué à s'entendre sur les
termes exacts que va faire pour vous le
présent la république est-ce qu'il peut
passer en force et organisé qu'en maine
un référendum non nous ne pouvons pas
passer en force et notre constitution
qui exige un accord des deux assemblées
et donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
vraiment la balle est dans notre camp à
tous les deux sénat et assemblée pour
parvenir à un texte commun
je crois que nous y sommes presque nous
sommes vraiment il faut vous l'avez très
bien montré avec ses différents
sémantique mais on est sûr nous nous
avons adoptée elle garantit la
préservation de l'environnement et de la
diversité biologique a menti exactement
et le sénat voulait elle préserve
l'environnement ainsi que la diversité
biologique donc la différence maintenant
c'est soit elle préserve soit elle
garantit la préservation niveau
d'ambition laissons ce gentil que pour
vous et pas seulement une bataille
sémantique masséne madail sémantique qui
veut dire quelque chose
qu'est ce qui va ce qu'est ce que ça va
changer dans le quotidien des français
si cette réforme processionnelle venait
à aboutir sachant que généralement je
crois que c'est vraiment dire que chaque
politique publique ne pourra plus se
faire sans avoir cet objectif très haut
de préservation de l'environnement et de
la diversité biologique c'est important
c'est un c'est plus qu'un signal que
l'on envoie c'est vraiment nous
souhaitons nous contrainte parce que
nous considérons aujourd'hui nous sommes
pas les sens symbolique cette année mais
juste symbolique et nous ne sommes pas
les seuls on nous alerte de toutes parts
et on le voit le réchauffement
climatique est là et qu'il faut agir si
vous le souhaitez vous donc ça c'est ce
changement finalement de la constitution
pourquoi vous réunissiez pas le congrès
députés sénateurs et vous changez
finalement signé avant de réunir le
congrès il faut quand même parvenir à un
texte commun
donc la balle car j'ai pu donc il faut
pas sur le président qui décidera s'il
préfère le référendum où le congrès
savez je ne veux pas vous
personnellement moi alors ça n'est
absolument pas dans mes prérogatives et
vous l'aurez bien compris moi mes
prérogatives c'est de réussir à parvenir
à un texte commun
j'y mets toutes mes forces me rapporteur
également donc vraiment mon ma
responsabilité elle est placée à ce
niveau là et je l'en dos pleinement
brume qui vit on va passer à cette
annonce officielle le sénat qui a lancé
une commission d' enquête pour faire la
lumière sur les couacs constaté à
l'occasion du premier tour des élections
régionales et départementales
[Musique]
4 millions de français n'auraient pas
reçu les professions de foi des
candidats avant le premier tour des
régionales la faute à un énorme raté
dans la distribution des plis mme
distribution qui a été en partie confiée
à une entreprise privée
et cette semaine gérald darmanin est
venu s'expliquer devant les sénateurs on
voit ça avec cécile 6 ou pourquoi des
milliers de français n'ont pas reçu la
propagande électorale avant le premier
tour des régionales
le sénat veut savoir et a donné
officiellement jeudi les pouvoirs de
commission denquête à sa commission des
lois est pour elle est adoptée la
commission des lois se voit conférer
pour une durée de six mois
les prérogatives attribuées aux
commission denquête pour mener cette
mission d'information dans la ligne de
mire des sénateurs le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin
mercredi matin il est passé une première
fois sur le grill en commission les
sénateurs ont cherché à connaître les
causes de ce qu'il qualifie de fiasco
mais aussi si cette non distribution des
professions de foi a pu jouer sur
l'abstention
nous avons beaucoup de témoignages de
gens qui ne sont pas allés voter
simplement parce qu'ils n'avaient pas
reçu cette propagande quand la question
de la perte de chance va se poser il est
vrai que les 32 millions de français qui
ne sont pas allés voter ne sont pas
allés voter uniquement pour cette
question technique ce que vous
considérez que la sincérité du scrutin
est entaché il ya plusieurs
jurisprudence du conseil d'état qui
évoque des distributions non distribués
du tout des communes qui par contre j'ai
rappelé commune d'annecy par exemple
qu'il avait eu aucune propagande et le
conseil d'état a toujours considéré
qu'il ne s'agissait pas de difficultés
profondes de sincérité du scrutin
ces réponses n'ont semble-t-il pas été
convaincante pour les sénateurs de la
commission qui l'après midi même l'ont
de nouveau invectivé lors des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
votre fiasco de la distribution a abouti
dimanche à une abstention record
comment comptez vous monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur stoppez votre
hold up de la démocratie puisque c'est
la faute de tout le monde sauf la vôtre
monsieur le ministre il reviendra à la
commission d' enquête du sénat de
définir l'ampleur des dysfonctionnements
observés dimanche la commission denquête
devrait débuter ses travaux début
juillet et rendre ses conclusions le
21 juillet prochain cette commission
donc c'était une nécessité selon vous ce
qui est important et c'est dans nos
missions constitutionnelles c'est de
contrôler c'est de contrôler l'action du
gouvernement
nous le faisons nous le faisons
régulièrement mois notamment
j'ai convoqué à plusieurs reprises le
ministre de l'intérieur sur des
opérations de maintien de l'ordre par
exemple pour comprendre comment ça a pu
et où ça a dysfonctionné j'ai auditionné
également je me rappelle la garde des
sceaux quand il ya eu une évasion
célèbre dans une dans une prison donc le
contrôle du parlement il est
indispensable et c'est ce que nous
faisons c'est ce qu'a fait la commission
des lois en auditionnant gérald darmanin
et c'est ce que je ferai dès mardi en
auditionnant également le ministre de
l'intérieur et les opérateurs dont ce
contrôle il faut l'effectuer après nous
attendons des réponses et des réponses
précises parce que là on a deux est ce
que vous voulez savoir non pas
d'opération nous vote et on voit bien
quand il ya eu une abstention manifeste
on en parlera tout à l'heure on peut
essayer de trouver des solutions autour
du vote par correspondance etc
mais il faut déjà que les professions de
foi et les bulletins parviennent aux
électeurs c est ce que vous allez
demandez vous aussi une commission
denquête de l'assemblée nationale ou
alors celle de mise en place par les
sénateurs suffit je verrai après mardi
en fait je pense que l'eau additionnée
de la barre vous verrez à voilà moi je
vais auditionné d'abord la commission
des lois va pouvoir questionner aussi le
ministre mais aussi les opérateurs parce
que moi je crois que c'est la très
important avec les entendants tateurs là
les prestataires qu'est ce qui s'est
passé quelle est leur cahier des charges
ou est-ce que ça a fauté et puis ce qui
est important et c'est la raison pour
laquelle moi je souhaitais également
placé ses auditions après le deuxième
tour
est-ce que ça a mieux marché au deuxième
tour est-ce que les correctifs qui ont
été apportées on voit par exemple que la
poste après le premier tour après c'est
un million d'envois donc après mon 2 le
deuxième taux est ce que ces correctifs
apportés 11 mars
et est-ce que c'est l'amélioration y
aura commission denquête après moi je
regarderai à ses intérêts
alors je ne sais pas aujourd'hui à
l'heure actuelle je ne sais pas je fais
le contrôle tels que je voulais indiqué
et puis moi je consulterai bien
évidemment les autres membres de la
commission des lois pour savoir ce qu'il
souhaite s'ils souhaitent aller plus
loin il ya différents forme d'un
d'investigation mais l'important c'est
pas la forme de l'investigation c'est de
faire les investigations du compte que
je fais dès mardi celle du contrôle il
n'y a pas de ceux n'a pas le pouvoir une
commission de sept femmes se substitue
pas ce sens qu'elle judiciaires qui
peuvent être lancés fils de forain ils
ne font pas parce que ce n'est pas le
rôle du parlement mais contrôlé
étroitement l'action du gouvernement
c'est une bien sûr constitutionnel a
rempli et autres homologues ici au sénat
françois noël buffet parle de cette
affaire comme d'un fiasco comment vous
qualifiez vous cette affaire encore une
fois moi je préfère entendre tous les
protagonistes avant de tirer les
conclusions
donc regardons ce qui s'est passé
regardons si c'est aussi ça c'est déjà
comprendre un petit peu quels ont été
les mécanismes et puis voir quels sont
les correctifs qui ont été apportées et
voir s'il faut en apporter des plus
profonds mais en tout état de cause
évidemment von teese grave non a
justement un souci quand les professions
de foi quand les bulletins de vote alors
j'ai dit que même les électeurs on ne
peut pas après leur reprocher tu pas
aller aux urnes
justement est elle porteuse jardin man
indique qu'il faut mettre fin à la
concurrence dans la distribution des
documents électoraux est ce que vous
souhaitez vous aussi une
renationalisation de ce service public
de la distribution de la propagande
électorale comme on tient ce qui est
certain c'est qu'il faut que ce soit
fiable mois d'après les informations que
j'ai mais encore une fois
elles vont se confirmeront c'est
infirmeront la poste a eu aussi des
difficultés dans les acheminements donc
il faut vraiment regarder parce que
l'objectif c'est que ça marche bien
donc si le service public a eu autant de
défaillances que le privé ça veut dire
que là n'est pas la clé donc il faut
regarder où est la clé et je pense
qu'elle est à chaque fois
multifactorielle il n'y a pas juste une
raison qui peut expliquer ces
problématiques donc comprenons ce qui
s'est passé pour y apporter les bons
correctifs mais ce qui est sûr ce qui
est sûr c'est que ça ne doit plus se
reproduire
est ce qu'il existe une responsabilité
personnelle de gérald darmanin dans
cette affaire il avait été averti des
risques un peu avant notamment ici au
sénat plusieurs fois à l'occasion des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
vous savez on a toujours des problèmes
d'acheminement
tous les sénateurs et les députés que
vous côtoyez de cette ampleur on entend
dire que quand nous faisons des lettres
bilan annuel et que nous les faisons
boîte et par tel ou tel prestataire
on a toujours beaucoup beaucoup de
citoyens qui viennent nous voir en nous
disant on n'a rien reçu mais vous ne
nous informer jamais de ce que vous
verrez ces visions de france n aime pas
on n'a pas reçu les plis électoraux ça
mais c'est colossal non mais je suis
bien d'accord donc après ces prêts
d'ariza bibliothèque humaniste et
franchement le ministre on a bien vu
il a immédiatement âge il a
immédiatement convoqué les entreprises à
beauvau il a immédiatement pris les
correctifs nécessaires
donc franchement encore une fois il faut
pas faire de la petite politique c'est
des sujets trop grave il s'agit du vote
de nos concitoyens donc allons chercher
les défaillances pour pouvoir les
corriger pour faire en sorte que cela ne
se reproduise plus et ne faisons pas de
la petite politique là dessus ça ne sert
à rien et en tout cas ça ne servira pas
nos concitoyens 66 7 % des français ne
sont pas allés voter dimanche dernier
aux élections régionales comment
l'expliquer et surtout donc comment y
remédier c'est une question sur laquelle
va peut-être devoir se pencher le
parlement
[Musique]
le président de l'assemblée nationale a
décidé de réagir
il a annoncé qu'il prendrait des mesures
dans les prochains jours pour traiter le
problème de l'abstention lors des
questions d'actualité c'était ce mardi
on écoute dès la semaine prochaine je
proposerai des initiatives en ce sens
mes chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
je suis soucieux mais je sais que le
propre de cette innovation que nous
appelons en démocratie et de pouvoir par
la volonté commune se renouveler et se
perpétuer alors c'est quoi cette
initiative il ya le brand qui vous en
savez plus tout le monde en ce moment
réfléchis et je crois qu'il est
particulièrement salutaire que le
président de l'assemblée nationale
lancent des initiatives sur le sujet
parce que la personne ne peut se
satisfaire de l'abstention et vous savez
nous sommes tous des élus une légitimité
nous la tire ont dû suffrage du fait que
des citoyens aient mis notre bulletin
avec notre nom dans une urne et donc
nous sommes tous concernés vous
représenter la majorité donc est ce que
vous vous proposez propose à
l'abstention on peut proposer beaucoup
de choses il ya des les les propositions
un petit peu j'allais dire technique
c'est à dire il faut simplifier il faut
simplifier les modalités de vote vote
par correspondance vote électronique
vote par procuration peut-être vote par
anticipation les machines à voter tout
ce qui va faire que lala vraiment là le
vote le geste de voter soit plus simple
plus moderne qu'est ce que c'est mais
joubert ça ne sera pas suffisant ça ne
sera pas suffisant mais je pense que
c'est essentiel après je pense que il
faut simplifier la lisibilité de notre
vie démocratique on a beaucoup entendu à
l'occasion de ces élections on sait pas
pourquoi on vote on sait à quoi servent
les deux mesures les régionales sur ces
prêts pour s'impliquer
moi j'en ai en fait d'eux une je crois
qu'il faut qu'on revienne en tout cas
qu'on s'interroge très sérieusement sur
le conseiller territorial qui avait
porté nicolas sarkozy donc réunir avoir
le même conseiller qui est également et
le conseil départemental et conseil
régional n'aurions plus qu'une seule
élection et après je crois qu'il faut
simplifier la le
la temporalité des scrutins et qu'on ait
le même jour des élections nationales
présidentielle et législatives et que
après nous ayons le même jour un temps
locales municipales et élections
désistement talent régional du temps
donc de temps très clair et très lisible
pour nos concitoyens enjeux nationaux
enjeux locaux
le jeu ça c'est quelque chose qui serait
de nature à en tout cas bien à gagner en
fait de la clarté de la simplification
et donc de la compréhension pour nos
combats le vote par internet toulouse y
est favorable
moi je suis plutôt favorable à ce qu'on
en tout cas ce qu'on regarde très
sérieusement aujourd'hui nos jeunes je
vois mes enfants c'est le smartphone qui
qui est greffée sur au bout de leurs
bras et donc regardons très sérieusement
le vote par internet certains pays le
font
il faut évidemment que certains pays
sont venus aussi réalisé suis 6e
instauré et finalement et ne le
pratiquent plus est la raison pour
laquelle il faut qu'on regarde on peut
pas évacué d'un revers de la main la
piste du vote électronique maintenant il
faut regarder pour voir si effectivement
c'est sécurisé et quelles sont les
expériences étrangères pour s'en
inspirer et à apprendre mais
sérieusement on est en 2021 il faut ça
se regarde évidemment ça se regarde
expériences étrangères notamment
l'exemple américain qui a beaucoup de
votes par correspondance vote par
correspondance en france pour ou contre
il alors il vote par correspondance
pourquoi pas encore une fois moi je
crois pas que ce soit la panacée
parce que ça n'est pas forcément d'une
plus grande modernité
en revanche aux états unis regroupe les
élections comme je le propose donc on
pourrait s'inspirer d'eux sur ce point
cette semaine on a appris sans que ce
soit encore officiel et dates de
l'élection présidentielle ce sera le 10
et 24 avril prochain c'est officiel
alors c'est les dates que j'ai comprise
maintenant ça sera annoncé en conseil
des ministres prochainement mais c'est
effectivement les dates qui se profile
mais ce que c'était une bonne idée de
faire fuiter ces dates en plein en
pleine élection alors que des gens
gens ont du mal à s'y retrouvent alors
je ne sais pas si sa fuite et au pas
mais en tout cas ce qui est certain
c'est que les gens ont besoin de clarté
déchéance de savoir où nous allons et
donc savoir que l'élection
présidentielle finalement se tient dans
neuf mois
et bien c'est ça donne un cap une
trajectoire et je pense encore une fois
que nos concitoyens ont besoin de ça ils
n'ont pas
ils ont besoin de savoir où on va et ça
c'est de nature à les éclairer sur
justement cette élection présidentielle
on va pouvoir voter avec les innovations
que vous proposez ou pas encore il va
falloir attendre
je ne crois pas parce que nous sommes
trop proche des élections et il faut
garantir la stabilité la sincérité du
scrutin on est sur des questions qui
sont très sensibles qui sont
constitutionnellement difficile à
européenne 2020 moi je crois qu'il faut
qu'avant il travaillait tranquillement
mais effectivement 2024 pourrait être un
bon cap
et il travaillait collectivement tous
partis confondus assemblée sénat mme
j'ai lancé une mission à l'assemblée
mais depuis plusieurs mois sur la vie
démocratique au 21ème siècle dont il
contient nécessairement ces sujets et
puis je voudrais rajouter quelque chose
pour conclure sur ce point moi je lance
un appel aux élus
moi je les les élus nous allons dans les
écoles nous y allons tous je crois mehal
allons-y plus montrons moi j'ai
tellement d'électeurs là de jeunes ont
dit je n'ai jamais vu un élu de ma vie
je ne sais pas ce que c'est un élu mais
allons dans les écoles allant dans les
écoles et ce sera le mot de la fin
les albres homme qui fait merci d'avoir
été l'invité de parlement hebdo bon
week-end à vous tous et bon vote ce
dimanche
[Musique]